himself up what actor do you know that
doesn't beat themself up I get depressed
I get self-defeating
I struggle a lot with like self-hatred
like I there's lots of parts of myself
that I hate depression sort of yeah it
tells you that everything will be [ __ ]
and it tells you everything has been
[ __ ] even the good things are bad I
circled the drain for a long time like
it it because my life was not turning
out the way I thought it would it's
rarely a setback it's the it's that you
get tired sometimes you get tired and
when you get tired then things start to
hit you and you cannot see a way around
you're unable to make a decision to move
either forward or backwards were you
really stuck in this very specific place
my grandma died and basically it was
like a big huge deal for me and then the
girl I grew up with next door guy and
killed by a drunk driver like a few
weeks before she died and then um and
then a few months later then the girl I
thought was spend the rest of my life
with dummy and I don't know why people
it's so taboo to talk about depression
or feeling isolated or feeling
disconnected it's almost like people
want to try to portray themselves as
being perfect and happy and everything's
great but that's not real life
when I started to understand what a
depression was the clinical definition
when you really get down to it is you're
unable to make a decision to move either
forward or backwards where you're really
stuck in it's very specific place and so
when I first moved to New York I didn't
realize that I had been going through
such a depression because I wasn't able
to write I wasn't able to I mean a play
essay anything I wasn't able to do
anything and I also wasn't able to make
a decision about what my life was about
to look like and so when I started to
deal with that I definitely decided to
get with a therapist and the start
really working through the process about
where I was and where I was eventually
trying to go and I've been able to
identify a lot of like the decisions
that I was making in the president we're
routing a lot of stuff that I had done
and dealt with in the past like losing
my job and trying to prove to people
that I had worthiness even though
something very valuable to me was
actually taken away and so one of the
things that the therapist said that
really began to transform me was one he
said nobody is responsible for your life
but you and how you engage and get back
to you is you do the things that you
want to do the things that you enjoy the
things that make you happy and through
that you will be able to kind of start
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel and hit a low point in New York
City one time and almost homeless and I
literally was getting high all the time
on different things and I was on the
street I had my hand out I was begging
for money and this older lady came by
one day and she looked at missing man
kind of changed she looked at me she
walked by I thought she was going to ask
the next person if a little tap on my
back the same old lady I said yes ma'am
we got change she thought in my face she
she said son
do your mama know you're here doing this
I said no man she shook her head just
walked away then give me a dime I turned
around I sit on the steps
I never beg for money again you still
see her face yes oh yes I turned then
look likes of what I walked her she
walked two blocks and took a left and I
watched her change my wife reminding him
my parents told me and I got a college
education and I had a master's degree
and blablabla my mother and father with
a second and third grade and they never
asked anybody for anything I had to
carry that legacy on change my life
during lights-out I've got pretty
depressed there for a while when it's
like it's just that shock of oh this
isn't what I thought it was gonna be or
like I didn't think it was gonna turn
out this way when you see something but
I think I mean on everything I've done
halfway through I get really depressed
that's true for the shorts even like
every short look than I've made halfway
through I want to quit cuz I'm like this
is [ __ ] this is garbage I want to do it
and then she convinces me to actually go
through with it and then you're very
happy about it later on and that's sort
of the thing that's happened on every
move like halfway through you're like oh
this is this is bad this is not what I
wanted and but you have to go through
with it and then even on lights out the
producer told me that you know when you
see your first cut you're gonna be you
know not very happy who were like the
first sort of assembly of it because he
was saying that you know when Ben
Affleck saw the first cut of Argo he was
like my career's over
and then he like won an Oscar and
everything and that's even though I was
told that first time I saw the cut first
kind of lights out it was like well this
is [ __ ] I've ruined I [ __ ] this up you
know maybe they can cut a cool trailer
of it but the movie is terrible but then
you just keep working out you cut out
all those little things that bother you
and you get the music in there and the
DI and everything and then at the end
it's like it's actually pretty cool so
but but on lights up for the
post-production there I was quite
depressed and really thought it was bad
until we had a test screening and I
could hear the audience and feel that
energy I sigh okay and then that's when
it started like okay maybe this is
pretty good and that that happens on
every movie and also after every movie
wraps I also get depressed but now after
three movies I know myself very well so
I'd sort of get through it better like
when Shazam was wrong winding down I was
talking to a lot about how yeah I'm
gonna get depressed afterwards and it's
gonna be pretty hard but I know it's
coming
I'm sure enough it does and then since
you've been through it so many times you
were able to write it out better because
like it's temporary even though when
you're depressed it never feels
temporary because depression sort of
yeah it tells you that everything will
be [ __ ] and it tells you everything has
been [ __ ] even the good things are bad
you know so yeah every every I think
that every movie is a roller coaster but
with highs and lows throughout I mean
that's happened to my brother as well
who makes video games like he spent
seven years making a video game and then
it's done I mean it's that thing of I
don't know if it's if we think that more
is gonna change like you work hard for
like two years like on Shazam or
whatever or
a movie and like you come out of it and
like you almost think that the world is
gonna be different now where you were
gonna be different and then it's sort of
like oh it's back to the same kind of
and it's sort of a break-in routine
especially when you have like on a movie
like this you have a routine you have a
purpose you know what you're doing and
like every day you come in you see the
same people you know you eat lunch
together and you talk and you get to
know each other and then one day it's
over and it's like it's kind of like
getting fired or almost someone dying or
something it's just like oh we're sort
of back to this and it's like yeah
thinks were you don't change as much as
you expect almost cuz you're building to
this big thing and then comes out and
even if yeah it makes money and it's
great and people love it but it's still
that feeling of like alright well what
now or like you're kind of back to
square one and in some ways which is
which is weird but it's yeah it's a part
of life I guess I guess you just have to
get to know yourself better and sort of
like yourself even more because even
though you do this big thing you're
still the same person and if you're not
comfortable with who you are you know no
big movie or big projects it's kind of
really gonna change that that's just
sort of things around it or you could
just start a new project that's the
thing I mean right now it's like oh I
have to get started on something new and
I think what's interesting is I I worked
with celebrities for so long and you
know celebrities really create the
persona that they want the the public to
see them as and I kind of working around
that promise myself that no matter what
if a camera was rolling or if I was in
front of the camera that I would be
myself no matter you know that I would
reveal whatever it is that I was feeling
and I don't know why people it's so
taboo to talk about depression or
feeling isolated or feeling too
connected it's almost like people want
to try to portray themselves as being
perfect and happy and everything's great
but that's not real life I can
understand the business side of of
making films and you know it's a lot of
money and it's a lot of people's money
and my lawyer my agent both felt like me
talking about addiction suicide
depression anxiety talking about that in
the public and that it would hurt my
career that I would you know not be able
to be insured or hired and I didn't
agree with them I didn't agree because I
felt like this journey was about me
getting better this journey was about
meeting these people and showing that
when you have face-to-face interaction
and you come with an open heart that we
help each other we help each other grow
we help each other get through things so
you know I I sort of went the exact
opposite of what they told me to do and
I'm so glad that I did and I no longer
work with them my case case of every
filmmaker out there you you you see that
spark and you love it you fight and you
sacrifice everything to get there and
you do it you do it you do it and then
it doesn't quite happen the way you
think you're not plucked out of
obscurity like some of these guys are
you're still working in the trenches for
years and it's a look I can't get
frustrating and then in my case I did a
film that had a lot of controversy
around it and was never ultimately
released and it was so utterly
devastating because after so many years
of just working and working and working
in sacrifice this film looked like it
was going to really be something and
then instead it's not released and
there's a lot of controversy and bad
press and all those ugly things and it
just it devastated me so much that I I I
didn't know if it was worth it and I
circled the drain because it's hard to
go from something like that from a film
that was so artistically satisfying such
a great script and all these things to
go from that to going back to trying to
find work as a
doing more corporate stuff like us like
how do you even what am I to do like I I
circled the drain for a long time like
it it because my life was not turning
out the way I thought it would and this
is everyone's story right everyone like
we all think we know how it's gonna turn
out any wife does this to you and goes
back this way and you know so for a few
years I didn't know my wife suggested to
me maybe we should just sell everything
and go teach English in Korea and I
seriously thought about it and it got to
a point with me where I had to just it
stripped everything away from me and got
me back to the basics of what do I
really love it forced me to wear it take
another look at what do I love about the
film industry in filmmaking and
storytelling him I found that spark
again like I just I loved moving people
and crafting stories and I'd love to see
people laugh when they're supposed to or
jump when they're supposed like I have
worked my whole life for that if there's
no feeling and no I don't know anything
else I couldn't do anything else and I
and I also had to you know and take it
experience and try to see all the good
that came out of it because a lot of
good did he and move forward which is
what's not easy but you know it yeah
that's the other thing they don't tell
you in film school is what happens when
discouragement hits cuz it does like it
can you know especially when the success
doesn't come when you think it will you
know or it builds up to it and feels
like you're being blamed or something I
mean there is like and I started this
way by saying this there is we are sold
on this idea that the filmmaking will
happen in a certain way like the Duplass
brothers were speaking at it is film
festival years ago what I saw I read
this article somewhere and they said
here's what you do you make your film
for 500 bucks and then you get
distribution and you'll make some money
on it then you make your second film and
you put
a big star in it and that'll do well on
the festival circuit yeah well it might
happen that way but it might not for
most people that's not how it happens
you'll make your film and you'll
mortgage your house and then nothing
happens that's so common that was all
the time the film disappeared on Netflix
and that's the end and now what and you
know you're not discovered and you're
not picked from obscurity and so then
what do you do from there do you keep
going
how much do you really love this how
hard are you willing to write that next
script get the next one going fight for
the next client with everything you've
got
and fight that cynicism that wants to
just rare it's ugly little head yeah
that's that's where the love of it will
really you better discover it you better
know why you love it and I do think it's
worth fighting for all the negativity
all the challenges all the frustrations
is worth fighting through to get there
because it really is great like when
you're on set and it's working and
you're telling that story and the actors
are there the cinematography look
nothing it's so like all of that
disappears and just fades away and
you're just like wow I'm creating this
amazing moment and it's working yeah
it's worth fighting for no question it's
not like I wanted to Tidus felt like I
could die you know and like I don't
think I've ever been like a suicidal
person but there's so many times where
I'm on the road and I'm like mmm maybe
I'll just run off the cliff right now I
think I mean that happened so many times
you know and all it takes is that one
second we just say [ __ ] it and he
actually do it and I've never done it
obviously um I mean sometimes it's not
even like I feel like dying sometimes
it's like I feel so numb I'm in so much
pain that I've actually become numb that
I want to maybe crash my car into a pole
and hope that nothing bad happens it
just really hurts and it kind of wakes
me back up like okay now you're alive
wait you know wake up and get back to it
you know so I have those kind of I guess
feelings it's not like I've ever had all
I'm gonna put a gun to my head I'm gonna
take a bunch of pills I've never
actually thought that way but it's been
more it's always driving is I Drive a
lot and so it's always been more like
I'm now get really depressed and then
I'm always driving so it's a lot of
times I'm on the road and I'm just like
you know I don't know but you you didn't
I never do yeah I mean time that this
happened and that's when you heard about
Alyssa is it Bustamante yeah okay that's
when you heard about Alyssa Bustamante
so was that did you somehow become
obsessed with that cuz sometimes there's
like something that'll break us out of
our own like troubles and we kind of
zero in on that probably yeah because
I'd been made out to be a monster and
then I saw her being made out to be a
monster and then I saw a lot of you know
similarities you know of me and her and
then so yes I guess my you know it's
like kind of grabbed my attention off of
that and put on that but was interesting
you know it only took us four days to
shoot the film which was it was actually
the best most fun I've ever had to shoot
in a movie was so easy it was like the
easiest shoot in the world but then I
had to sit on the film but we felt like
an April but then I got dumped in July
and it was an insanely bad breakup and
then um that's when I finally finally
started editing so I actually that's
when I became obsessed I think is after
the breakup because that's when I
actually started putting the film
together and then I literally felt like
I only had this film I mean that that's
what happened is a you know I kind of
made the movie it took my attention off
the the thing that happened to me in the
media and then I went back to kind of
life the relationship issues and then a
couple months later then that was over
and then I'd that's when I was just like
didn't want to live and I kind of like
became sunken in depression with this
movie and then became obsessed with it I
guess you know so I'm always depressed
over a girlfriend and then I come up
with something so like how much porn
star killer or like when I did that I
had never made a feature and attempted
multiple times since
was ten to make a feature and and I had
shot three features and I could just
could never finish them so in 2000 when
I was 24 after getting dumped by my
first long-term relationship there was a
bad year in general and that was
actually the worst year was my grandma
had died and she was like basically my
mom to me like am i I have my mom but I
mean my mom's blinds my grandma did a
lot of mom stuff so my grandma and my
mom kind of like they were like my two
moms in a way so my grandma died and
basically it was like a big huge deal
for me and then the girl I grew up with
next door a guy and killed by drunk
driver
like a few weeks before she died and
then um and then a few months later than
the girl I thought was a spin I risk my
life with dummy and so that was the
first point I think aside from all the
times I'm when I was a kid where I
didn't wanted to die this was the first
time I think my adult life I wanted to
die now like I had another break up you
know in October but the girl didn't move
out until just this April and so it was
tearing me up this whole time so I don't
even feel like we broke up until April
and so I've been doing films now that I
think have been saving my life from now
like the past two months I've never
worked so much my life and then that was
too you know because I was feeling all
suicidal again I guess after her so I I
guess every time I make a movie you know
is it's kind of saving my life rarely do
I make a movie where I'm like really
happy and hey I'm making a movie it's
usually life sucks and this movie is
saving my life you know if that answers
the question usually I'm always in a
state of life sucks and and a movie
saves my life so maybe that's why maybe
that's why people get something out of
it cuz I'm always kind of pouring I
guess a lot of heart and soul into it
I'm never just doing it I'm never just
doing it to kill time you know it's it's
always to get my mind off of stuff you
know I have to say they having to drink
before a phone call and feeling so alone
and feeling like I was going to blow
every opportunity and I was never gonna
reach my potential and that was
something that I would feel daily
because I couldn't go out I remember one
time taking a big hit off my bong and
then running down the stairs to get the
mail
because that's the only way I could get
the mail and I bumped into the mailman
and exhale and I'm like oh my god I
could never get the mail now like I blew
my one thing I could do and then I go
back up and drink and also my husband
was gonna leave me so I remember it one
time I was a bad drunk and I was waiting
for him to come home and I thought I
wonder if I have time to to to pour
myself a drink and I thought no I'll
have to drink it from the bottle and I'm
drinking it the bottle smashes as red
wine everywhere and turns that I had
enough time because the guy never came
home that night he said yeah if you were
such a drunk I'd come home and I said
sorry so I think that was pretty painful
okay no wonder I pushed it out
I turned to Kalama comedy wellness again
okay one time I was with a guy who I'm
the one who pretended he was British he
hit me and I would I love myself in the
bathroom I was in the bathtub and I was
shaking and I said ma I found my own
Nazi so you know I made how could I made
my own Holocaust I'm like in the
bathroom I was you know and he tried to
get me deported oh my goodness so I
think that that was probably a low I was
kind of used to throwing up in bathrooms
all over town I cuz that's how I drank I
drank to the point of blacking out I was
rarely remembered the end of the evening
or look the same at the beginning of the
evening yeah so uh but I never learned
I never stopped until I was able to find
some meetings where people were I walked
in and they he were people sharing it
you threw up on in Spago's - oh my
goodness what else
horrible embarrassing things have you
done the same things that I did you know
they found a man they found the booze
they found the drugs and they once
thought they were like sober now and I'm
like okay I'm gonna keep coming back you
know this is yeah this is
this is something I have to learn I have
to read up on but I didn't okay so the
next day they said you see you can't
share at a meeting unless you have 24
hours of sobriety and I want I was like
a guy I'm Canadian good little alcoholic
you know I wasn't gonna do that
so I thought how am I gonna get 24 hours
of sobriety I thought okay cuz my plan
was to go to one meeting go home and
drink myself to death no not all at once
just eventually cuz I had already had a
bad liver report at 26 and UCLA that and
they told me my liver was going I had a
bad liver panel and they told me to stop
doing everything I'm like I went home
and got so drunk cuz I thought oh my god
this is gonna kill my mother the
Holocaust survivor I'm gonna die before
her anyway so I got really really drunk
you know so I I thought okay how am I
gonna get through this 24 hours so I can
share and I was even offered cocaine and
it was incredible I just thought no I
must share I must share once before I
died he always thought leader so I
thought okay just get through the night
get through the night and I did and I
went to my next meeting and I shared for
the first time but put up my hand and
I'm like you guys are taking cakes and
chips for like 10 years I couldn't get
10 minutes how do you do it and this
little old lady who's probably about 10
years younger than me turns around and
goes oh honey we do it one day at a time
I'm like like a sitcom okay I am gonna
try this and I just kept going a lot of
meetings and here we are 36 years later
still sober because you know I learned
first of all I didn't realize the guy
that I was living with was bald and I
didn't know he wore a weave oh how did
you find out well
occurred to me his hair was like
unusually thick you know that I'm sober
I was like getting a new pair of glasses
there's actually a book like that so one
night when he's kept drinking heavily
so I'm sober I'm like obsessed with his
hair that was so we could know like I'm
gonna find out what's under there so I
like crawl over there very quietly and I
lift the thing because he'd had a whole
bottle of wine and I saw it was a weave
it was like stuck on and then I realized
his eyes were open and he's looking at
me and I'm like I put it down I went
back to my side of the bed we're bad we
never spoke of it but I thought if I
didn't know my own husband was bald what
else have I been missing I better stay
sober because that would mean you would
think that would be obvious what else
what else did I get wrong turns out a
lot
I got a labra do you think that's wise
storytelling is important because you
wanted to tell your story which was real
and that is sharing in a meeting and
essentially you're telling a story of
either your day or your life or what
you're struggling with I had to be a
writer I had to tell people one of the
reasons I felt I survived in certain
circumstances was I needed to tell
someone what I went through which I
heard some Holocaust survivors say to
they survived because of luck and the
need to tell people what went on that
there is a passion and a belief and a
support for the pain from depression to
PSD to you know that you're not alone
and that you know we we've gone down
this journey with you and you know their
healing can happen and obviously it's a
slow long drawn-out process but for sure
this is something we can all get over
eventually right I would I would
actually second that you know you're not
alone and I know a lot of movies like to
tie everything up in a nice pretty bow
and everything's fine everybody moves on
and it's great and we're all happy and
healthy and we wanted to just make sure
that it stayed real to the ending of
their on the road back and they all know
it's a long road but they're all
and they're you know they're in the
buggy chugging along knowing that there
if you're willing and a willing
participant in healing it can happen you
just have to you have to be there and
stay present and willing to work through
it how real the situation is because
it's one of those things where I don't
know if people really are in tune or
want to address how dark depression and
and PSD can be and to hear people come
to us and say my grandmother she
completely separated or my father and my
and that's that's one of those things
that you didn't expect to connect you
know we were just kind of telling the
story for our own process and it
developed into a movie from there and
then you know actually we puttin it out
so you don't expect people to grab you
in the lobby and just talk to you and
talk to you and talk to you about so
much of their own personal view so we're
helping them to heal that they're not
alone so that's been a gift
absolutely it's been a true gift this is
a calling to me this is a calling to be
this see when you when it's a calling
there's nothing that can take you away
from it I mean you know you get sick or
whatever like my mother fell and hurt
herself now if I had to go and I went
home for a couple of weeks to tend to my
mother if I had to go home to take care
of my mother I would do that cuz he
family comes first you know if I had to
say okay I'm gonna have to go home for a
while I would do that see so it's not
like no no no if this is if this is an
emergency situation that always to me
takes precedence over this because you
can't I couldn't be happy or really
concentrate knowing that my mama or
somebody needs me
and they helpless I couldn't you know
you can't you can't function so I mean I
would do that but if it's about the fact
that you know the pool like I dated a
girl that was here from Chicago and we
went to see a movie and
at the Sherman Oaks Galleria and when we
left a movie she got a call from her
from her mother anyway having a cookout
in the backyard or something so this is
like we went to see her like a early
matinee you know around 12 or something
like that so after the movie was always
around 2 o'clock or whatever
back in Chicago was 4 o'clock and it was
on I think of Saturday or something
and her mother calls oh because oh we
got barbecue
we got potato salad we got all of this
stuff Oh everybody asking about you
and we were walking going to you know
you we walk into the car you know you've
been in the gallery right so we were
walking to the car on the ground and
then she stopped dead in her tracks and
start talking and all of a sudden she
said ok I'll call you back mom I'll call
you back she hung up on the phone and
stopped broke down start crying so
naturally people who walking past it
what did you do what people looking at
me like did you hit her did you I'm like
I'm just standing here she started
crying and said I want to go home and we
got in the car and she cried and cried
we didn't even we didn't even take off
we just sat in the car and she said what
should I do I said you should go home
she said really I said oh I say you you
you need to go home because you feeling
that she said but I don't I said don't
worry about me or your agents and all
these people you got to do what's best
for you
if it means being in this business being
this business if it means going home go
she went home there was one woman that a
long time after it happened
thanked me privately for you know
spending some time and talking with her
and
kind of talking her down I mean she's
just that at it
I remember the long conversation we had
on the telephone about you know why this
business sucked and there was no no
opportunity for advancement for her and
nothing was working and she just felt
like she was on a hamster wheel and
going nowhere and I said you know that
that may be true and it may not be true
you you may never go anywhere but you're
not gonna find out unless you stay and
try because it could happen tomorrow it
could happen tomorrow that's what
happened to me I mean I was just kind of
a workaday co-star occasional guest our
guy until I was brought in to audition
for an HBO show on a Saturday Saturday
that's very inconvenient for me I really
don't want to go into an audition on a
Saturday because I play softball on
Saturdays and maybe they'll do it a
different day agent can you get me in a
different day no they're just doing it
on Saturdays all right all right I went
in and there were 50 other guys there
and they all look like me on uh geez
this is ridiculous but I did my did my
job in the room and then I came back and
I came back again and the herd thinned
and thinned and pinned and thinned and
finally make a long story short I was
cast as ed haligan and Funny or Die
presents and Liz Paulson brought me in
for that for that role and that show
produced by Will Ferrell which was sort
of the TV version of the Funny or Die
website changed everything for me it put
me on radars that I previously had not
been on and and opened a lot of doors
for me and created opportunities that I
never would have had had Liz not brought
me in for that role and I will forever
be grateful to her for that yeah and and
and to just to finish the thought if you
don't stay and wait
for that opportunity you won't know so
yeah that that woman and I had a very
long conversation that night but I you
know I didn't I was just trying to give
her a pep talk but it turned out that it
was important to her and she stayed and
she's still here and working how do I
get to dark here but uh but I think
writing is inherently like the only
person you're battling is yourself
really most of the time because and I
think in particular at least for me I
can only speak to my experience but I I
struggle a lot with like self-hatred
like I there's lots of parts of myself
that I hate and I'm only sort of just
now getting over a lot of these types of
things but like when it's just you and a
blank screen and a cursor flashing
sometimes like all of your insecurities
and things just bubble up and it gets in
the way of you of you getting your
creative thoughts onto the page and I've
learned just for me like when I'm able
to give myself permission to write the
worst most terrible pages of all time
then I can do it and then I know in my
like in my back pocket I know that
writing is a process so I know that like
whatever I try on my first attempt is
probably not gonna be very good in fact
like you know the the terrible first
draft is like that's just kind of a law
in how I see it there are other people
who I'm sure are brilliant that can pump
out a genius first draft I am NOT that
person I will never be that person and
so for me when I'm allowed to give
myself grace and allow myself to write
terribly to just write things that don't
make sense to write sentence fragments
to write and then they fight I'll come
back later and then keep going you know
what I mean like when I allow myself
that sort of level of freedom then I can
write and I feel like on paper I
shouldn't be a writer because I'm like
myself critics
in my brain is pretty fierce and
sometimes it's unbearable but I think
that you you do you have to give
yourself grace and you have to like
again I don't want to be too new agey
but you gotta like kind of love yourself
you know what I mean you have to be okay
with yep
these are some terrible words but you
know their words and that's all that
matters right now in this particular
instance the only thing that matters is
like I'm putting words onto the page
they don't have to be the right words
and want to be in the right order but
their words and for at least for our
first draft that's the that's the thing
that I think when I learn that sort of
like you know unlocked in my brain I'm
just like oh this draft doesn't count it
doesn't count because I'm gonna I can go
back and fix it later
and so riding with a reckless abandon of
like this doesn't have to be good this
is supposed to be bad anyone can write a
terrible thing you know I mean terrible
just in terms of the mechanics of the
words like anybody can write something
terrible you know and like that's how I
find my entry into it it's like if
alright I know for a fact that I can
write something terrible if my goal is
to sit down and be a genius I can't hit
that every day but I can hit being
really bad every day and so that's my
only metric of success is like are there
words on the page yes I don't my metric
of success is not are they good words is
this good that's for that's for later
how do you feel on those days when you
have no time to work on your writing
I get really depressed I get depressed I
get self-defeating you know I've always
believed in some weird way that that I'm
you know the parable about the The
Tortoise and the hare are kind of a
thing you know I feel like I'm like The
Tortoise kind of and so I have a kind of
really really strong and present work
ethic that sometimes gets really
annoying you know so I have a really bad
guilty kind of conscience about not
working so there are certainly days
where I'm not doing any writing or not
doing any kind of you know work shopping
and and it's frustrating because you
feel like you haven't been productive
but I think going back to a bigger kind
of frame I think those moments are
important you know when I do experience
writer's block and I go and go for a
hike and zone out and I spend a day at
the beach or I'm watching a movie or
something I think a lot of good can come
from that you know gives you perspective
and distance from the project a little
bit and I also think that if you're not
writing you know either because there's
something wrong with the script with a
story or that something else is supposed
to happen that you have to tend to
whether it's life things or whether it's
whatever so I try not to beat myself up
too much about it but but I can be very
hard on myself for sure what we are I
think in this business so many of us
were where we're not treated as business
owners we're not treated as
entrepreneurs we treated as struggling
artists right but we are business owners
right we each are running our own
business with limited staff with you
know high overhead with trying to figure
out how to make our product different
from our competitors and we're all
struggling to find funding right and so
we have to kind of wear that hat with a
little more pride you know we are
business owners we're entrepreneurs and
so it's it's it's it's it is tough when
you are running your own business and
you feel like you know you're not going
to work on that one day and you feel
like no know what's going on so
you know I think it's I think it's I
think it's tough when I feel like I'm
not being productive you know I've read
a lot of kind of blogs and watched a lot
of interviews about other writers who
either have the luxury to write every
single day you know because they're
they're being paid to write a certain
script or that's how they work but and
III think for me I'm not sure that I'm
the kind of writer who writes every day
you know maybe I need to be a little bit
better about that I'm not sure but I try
to be mindful of what is inspiring to me
at the moment you know and letting that
energy build up you know so that I'm not
just sitting at a computer like staring
at a blank page you know for me I think
sometimes it's important to stare at a
blank page and other times it's really
important to just kind of like let that
energy build up and build up and build
up so that you have a lot to say you
know so that you have a lot to say and a
lot to express and you can put it all on
the page and I think that's important
too I've got my nerdiness and one of the
things is I always like to study people
who have been you know massively
successful or influential you know cross
a broad spectrum of disciplines and
industries and and there's one let me
ask you what do you think would be the
common the common denominator with the
most successful people I know that's
what a successful mean so let's just say
financially you know spiritually
emotionally psychologically physically
the most successful people what would
you think is the most common trait that
they have from what I've seen I think
people that are just obsessed with
something it doesn't even mean that
they're good people
or you know anywhere on the spectrum of
sort of intentions but I think being so
obsessed with whatever they are
into whether it's acting whether it's
stock trading whether it's real estate
whether it's painting whether it's
meditation I've seen people that just
have this laser focus with something and
they're obsessed with the immigrants
their life this week that is a very
common answer that certainly excuse me
that's certainly necessary you know the
the seminal book that Napoleon Hill
wrote Think and Grow Rich you have to
have that burning desire right white-hot
burning desire which in today's worlds
like I'm obsessed
everybody says obsessed it's not
necessarily the best word to use but
it's the word of the day so yes that's
it but but the the the trait that people
see that's that's kind of a given is
self compassion so sort of um
self-awareness or or of compassion
compassion can you can you take me
through that what that would be sure
self empathy so not beating up on one's
self there you go interesting I do not
have guessed that yeah well neither
would i but you all do from just reading
and studying different people
male/female different industries
different disciplines different races
origins you're gonna make mistakes you
are going to write so since we're
talking about acting and within this
film courage and writing there's a lot
of writers that watch this and I mean
what writer do you know that doesn't
beat themself up what actor do you know
that doesn't beat themself up right
right like there's that neurosis that's
always like sitting on the shoulder here
you know that anxiety is over here and
just like oh my god were they thinking
about me like give yourself a break
relax all right because reality is most
everyone not even thinking about you
that's true yeah they're thinking about
themselves PS they're having the same
conversation you are and they're
thinking you're thinking that about them
right right we're all human beings
all right give yourself a break you're
doing the best you can do with what you
have at that time and if you are
obsessed as we say you have that burning
desire whatever it may be
then just trust that you're gonna make
mistakes but that's how you learn
mistakes are a great thing I never used
to think that way if I sound I wonder
how that's that sounds probably crazy to
say that but it's the truth mistakes
mistakes are a blessing man number one
it means you're still alive you got
problems you're still alive
there's an old story some guy was taking
a guy and his son are driving through
town and kids talking about problems
problems problems you know Dan I just
wish I have any problems they drive by
the graveyard he goes you don't know one
place they don't have problems he points
to the graveyard those problems are good
there assign a life son so yeah yeah
it's the truth though right you're gonna
make mistakes that's how you learn man
that's how you learn pain is the
greatest teacher there is and everyone
runs from it to their detriment myself
included and from what I can make out
the type-a personality is the unhappy
workaholic who can't do anything in life
except work and who basically is making
himself and the people around him
miserable because of his work is this
obsessive need to be working all the
time and then there's a Type B
personality who never is very well
defined and and somehow doesn't become
an ideal SL yeh describes him but is
somebody who's well adjusted and doesn't
feel the same crazy pressures that's a
type a feels and I thought well the
problem with that theory is that it
leaves out people who absolutely love
their work and who are able to live you
know other full lives at the same time
and I started thinking about that and
realizing there a lot of people like
that and they're I call them type C's in
one of my books and the type C is the
creative personality that loves to work
would probably be rather be working than
anything else but isn't negatively
impacted by that at all instead they
just thrive on their work I mean there's
example I saw long ago as Pablo Casals
the great you know cellist was so
crippled with arthritis when he got to
be older that he had to be carried from
his bed
every morning to his piano bench and
because he warmed up everyday by playing
the piano for half an hour an hour and
but but he got to the point where he
couldn't walk to the bench he had to be
carried to the bench and then stacked on
to his bench and his arms had to be
lifted onto the keyboard and then he
would slowly but surely start playing
for an hour and at the end of the hour
he got up and walked too you know to the
kitchen for breakfast and he did this
every day in his last 10 years and he
was reactivating his body through the
Curia - you know the creative process
that he was very well in tune with and I
realized that type-c personalities are
people who have this you know creative
affliction or whatever you call it this
gift and but but understand it as
opposed to those who don't understand it
and who have often tragic endings like
Sylvia Plath or Hemingway or Virginia
Woolf or many others in the creative
world who never understand their process
who think that every time they finish a
book it's the end of the world and they
go into a deep depression this is very
common in the creative world is to be
depressed after you finish a work so
when you really think about that do the
solution is obvious never get to the
point where you're finishing a work and
that happens on the negative side for a
lot of people can never finish their
book or never finish their article or
never finish their poem because they're
afraid of finishing fear of finishing
and and as a tenured professor I was
always on committees judging other
people who couldn't finish anything and
one of my colleagues who like me had
published many books we were both on the
same committee judging another Kawa
colleague who had not finished a single
book and my colleagues said to me you
know you and I would would write a book
in the time it takes him to research a
chapter of a book and I said yeah
because I always do my Reese
last you know I write the book first Lin
did the research and so I already know
it's going to end but and to get back to
this finishing idea of finishing a
simple solution to this postpartum
depression is to when you know that
you're almost done when you know that
you're and the homestretch of a book or
of a screenplay or whatever it is stop
take a day off take two days off because
the energy of finishing is so huge that
it will easily be recalled when you sit
down again to allow it into this
compartment that you're using but take a
day off instead and it starts your next
project truly get into your next project
because every creative person has
another project that's dying to be next
so sit down and start it and go on it do
it to the point where you can't wait to
go on with it and then stop and go back
and finish the project you were
finishing and you'll discover that there
is no no no more any postpartum
depression because you haven't allowed
it
you simply managed the time you know the
finite commodity at your disposal
you've managed the time so you don't
have to deal with that because being
depressed is basically most of the time
a waste of time
for an artist you can allow it for a
while if it gives you great ideas and
deepens your pathos and the things that
you need to draw on but it's basically
too much of it as a waste of time and
you know one of my mentors years ago
John Gardner the novelist said people
should just start doing more it gets rid
of all the moods they're having you know
if you're in a down mood get up and run
around the block and literally that
works I mean if you get your body going
and run around the block it's hard to be
in that kind of morbid depressed state
you're in before so managing your moods
like that it's what separates a
productive happy creative person from a
productive unhappy creative person you
notice I'm not talking about the
unproductive
that's a whole different subject but I'm
talking about people who are creatively
productive and have careers they're
still divided into the unhappy ones and
the happy ones and it's a matter of
understanding I think how your mind is
working that makes you part of the happy
group and you don't have to be part of
the unhappy group despite a lot of urban
myths to the contrary that basically say
the artists got to be suffering and
tortured and all of that that's really
not necessary
it's rarely a setback it's the it's that
you get tired sometimes you get tired
and when you get tired then things start
to hit you and you cannot see a way
around you know whereas if you got a
good night's sleep sometimes it's easy
sometimes it's hard I think it's the
wear and tear and that's where you
really have to say never get into this
life alone you know get get you always
have somebody to back you up a friend or
or you know in this case we have a
spouse who's a friend well so that table
when we have yeah we have the table
which talked about in one second but the
whole thing is to say this whole thing
about rugged individualism and by your
bootstraps that's just not the way
people operate you know it's one of my
favorite songs is lean on me and you
know and you know and someday I'll need
someone to lean on and I think that's
really true so it's the day-to-day grind
you know the you you always we hope for
something sometimes this how folks are
higher than mine so I don't have this
big setbacks because I'm always a little
more wary than he is it don't like oh
this is a great old you know so it's
like I'm much much you know it's a
bigger hit when it goes down but but
still it's that you know if you don't
expect to if you you know there's
somebody you can turn to and say I'm
just down today it's just I just had a
bad day and someone can say it's it's
okay you've got the you know somebody
can just say it's okay keep going
that that's the big I'd say just dealing
it with it with other people is the
trick and don't don't lock it down
Hollywood can be very corrosive it can
wear you down you have to really be very
careful of who you're giving judgement
to who's in judgment of you at where you
internalize
because if you if if it's people who are
hateful who are toxic or cruel that can
destroy you and so you have to you have
to surround yourself with people who are
loving people who are kind and it's it's
hugely important and because at the end
of the day you have to build a life the
life is ultimately more important than
this script or this project or any of it
you have to have a life where you're
loved and you're loving where you have a
have people who as Lance and when you
falter will be there for you and again
it has to be you know lean on me is good
if it's if it's going both ways
it isn't like well let me drain your
lifeforce and leave you an empty husk
you know which is what some people do
you know and so you have to make sure
that it's it's a reciprocal and that's
what we often say is your career will be
defined by two poles what you stand for
and what you won't stand for but you
have to know what those two things are
and and a lot of people particularly
actors actors can end up being very
successful but feeling very empty
because they're doing roles that are not
not an alignment with what they
themselves believe and so you have to
decide well what do I believe what is
meaningful to me and then how can I do
work that speaks from that and speaks to
that there's a habit of executives who
are not artists just sort of project who
the hell are you you know and it's very
hard to answer that but if you know what
you stand for
like if you say I said what I take a
stand for the message that I'm going to
give is that as long as you keep trying
as long as you're in the game in your
hair oh you know let's say that's what
you want to stand for and if if I say
well who the hell are you you say I'm
the person who stands for this message
and it's an important message and they
can't get to you in that way if you
really aren't clear on what you stand
for but but sometimes it's always hard
and the good thing about like at the
table let's see if made face you you
advertise I made five calls and it's
five knows but but then you're getting
applause for having picked up the phone
five times and that you're going to make
five more call for the next day you
could have plotted for going to you know
keep your going in the game you're still
fighting on and I think that we all sort
of need that it you say hey I made five
calls I'm gonna make five calls tomorrow
it's okay that's what it takes it takes
100 calls to get the one yes but I'm
going to
those hundred calls I'm gonna get that
yes and it's very interesting if you
track how people have struggled that my
favorite films if you listen to the
filmmakers
well they it took them ten years to get
it mounted it took you know lots of
insults it took people you know
battering them down but they ended up
making something brilliant which a lot
of people didn't see but they saw and
then they gifted me with it so I think
that it's more realistic to say hey
let's let's applaud each other for the
effort
I feel very free to to be Who I am and
that makes me feel free to be an artist
and to create organically the way that I
want to create and not have to have like
this set formula that I feel like
Hollywood kind of feeds you and makes
you think that you need so I feel great
I mean I feel like I'm you know I went
through such a hard year and this
project was really tough but now I'm at
a place where I finally get to do the
work that I want to do and I set that
bar for myself by saying you know what
I'm not gonna conform and do it the way
that you want me to do it I'm gonna do
it the way I want to do it as an artist
and it's just you know setting the tone
now for the rest of my work the rest of
my this things that I want to do last
night screening was the best screening
have ever had of anything I've ever done
because you know there were so many
tears and so much laughter and it just
felt like people really understood my
journey and what I went through like
they related to it and so many people
came up to me and said you know I
suffered from this and this gives me
hope that I can get through it and
that's what that's why I made it you
know I mean yeah I made it to go and
document a personal journey but I
thought in some way that if I could make
it through this depression if I could
find my artistic integrity again that
maybe it would inspire other people to
be able to do that too and to have the
courage to be able to get out there and
tell their stories no matter
who says that they shouldn't
you